hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tara's never seen and today
I am watching the phenomenon that was
Austin Powers come dressed a little 60s
70s yeah I think it said the seventies I
look like like a hippie Elvira
I'm excited honestly to see what this is
all about because it was such a big
thing and I don't know what the story is
I know he's a spy I know he like sleeps
with lots of women I think it's like a
James Bond type deal so let's do it
[Music]
okay okay it was fine it was cute and
there were some things that I laughed at
for sure I think this is my favorite
Mike Myers role but then again I think
the only other thing I've seen Mike
Myers in is Shrek the story is that he's
a spy punished trying to stop dr. evil
from creating nuclear blasts in the
world he wants money and he has to stop
blah blah blah whatever you really
forget about the plot of the story
because you're just watching Austin
danger powers go through all of these
different things and being a ridiculous
human and a ridiculous spy and a
ridiculous sex symbol and it's honestly
there's some really childish stupid
humor but that's what this film is and
it's fun it works a lot of the time a
big problem with the comedy for me is
that they just run jokes into the ground
there's I know that is the joke but they
take things way too far and it goes
wrong for so long that being said
weirdly enough the acting was was great
and enjoyable and served its purpose and
the comedy was what you wanted out of
this film you weren't looking for this
to be the next Shawshank Redemption so
like it's fun I loved the costume so
much it the opening was so high energy
and so much fun it opens on this great
dance number and Austin Powers is
running from all these women and
everyone's in amazing costumes I
honestly wish they would have kept it in
that time period because when they
brought it to the 90s though the play
with different times and messing up
things was really fun as well I just I
just so enjoyed the costumes and it
started off so high-energy and then
getting to the 90s it's like okay
there's room for jokes now that you
don't know what's going on in the 90s
but I just I just loved the beginning Oh
I thought dr. evil and his son Scott
were maybe my favorite parts of the film
I really loved their dynamic but of such
a funny joke
such a good guy mr. bigglesworth I love
you so much
doesn't take much to get me on your side
you just have to be a cat I really love
that dr. evil freezes himself and so
Austin Powers does as well they're not
doing it to like see future stuff
they're not doing it to be in a world of
advancement in the future they're just
doing it to get away from each other dr.
evil freezes himself to get away from
Austin Powers and that's it and then
awesome power teresa's himself so that
he can get dr. evil it just it doesn't
make any sense which is great and
hilarious I also love when they're
unfreezing Austin Powers they're in the
celebrity ward and you have vanilla ice
that like that's the celebrity and then
also that like vanilla ice would freeze
himself because he would I loved that I
thought that got maybe the biggest laugh
for me oh one of my favorite lines as
well was I am here to get you acclimated
to the 90s a lot has changed since 1967
okay was the 60s sweet and awesome
Baumer says no doubt no doubt but as
long as people are still having
promiscuous sex with many anonymous
partners without protection while at the
same time experimenting with mine
expanding drugs in a consequence free
environment I'll be sound as a pound I
truly enjoy that he is such a doofus and
then he's also portraying the sex symbol
I think it's so great he's disgusting
and body hair and like his crazy teeth
and and
just being Mike Myers I think it's
really fun that he gets to play this sex
symbol I wrote I love Will Smith I was
talking about Will Ferrell I love Will
Ferrell but the characters a little
maybe racist
his dying scene is funny that's another
one that they really just drug and drug
on sure was funny then but now it's just
kind of like this is a little dated this
junk style especially when you're doing
it every two seconds they also do that
with the long pee also with the penis
pump not being mine and then this is and
then he has the book and then he has all
the things and the warranties and all
that so it's just like a lot of it
happening all the time I wrote that will
Ferrell also ruined mr. bigglesworth so
I'm glad he's dead
just kidding mr. bigglesworth is still a
star without fur I love him the same
evil laughs commence
[Laughter]
so there's gonna be some like cringy
stuff when you're putting Mike Myers is
the sex symbol and then these beautiful
women opposite him there's gonna be
something that makes me a little
uncomfortable that was inevitable that
was gonna happen obviously we all knew
it but so his his like sexy assistant
who's the daughter of his other sexy
assistant it finally decides to go on a
date with him after he's pestered her
just like for sex a lot she's like fired
me where's-where's are down and there's
a scene where she's a little drunk and
he's doing all these really dumb gags
like though walking down the stairs
behind a couch and she has to be
laughing at him the whole time she's
like oh that's you in a nutshell he's
like no this is me in a nutshell oh god
I'm in a nutshell and it's like okay
chuckle worthy but not she's like
supposed to be like really laughing at
him and it's not playing really well
it's it's kind of like uncomfortable to
watch that I didn't love that part but I
do love that when she's drunk he doesn't
have sex with her he doesn't take
advantage of her it's like wow even
Austin Powers smokes even he knows lady
guards pretty awesome
and your video has been demonetised it's
the slow steamroller also wonderful but
I'm just listing off all these fun
things that happen because the story
really doesn't matter because it's just
all these funny bits from these funny
humans in this funny scenario but the
story really didn't stick with me at all
you know at the end of course they stop
him from doing the nuclear thing and
then they get married and blah blah blah
but like jokes jokes jokes jokes jokes
in between it's just fun and fluffy and
nothing versus a story that you have to
pay attention to 1 million dollars so
yeah it was it was fun it was pretty
much what I expected maybe a little more
funny than I expected like you can't go
into expecting it to change your life
obviously but you know it's harmless
I'm says stupid but harmless yes exactly
my thoughts exactly the sight of Mike
Myers and Union Jack panties will make
you cringe actually just the word
panties makes me cringe but I loved that
scene honestly with him dancing and
seducing these women because I loved the
lady robots and that they were designed
to seduce him but he was able to turn on
such charm and he seduces these robot
but it's dumb I loved it you'll think
mini-me is adorable I miss mini-me
[Music]
oh god that's gonna be so embarrassing
if I did
oh no minimis only in the second third
movies Twitter you'll spontaneously
applaud over the Carrie Fisher cameo I
was paying attention I swear oh my god
I ain't none of those Kingfisher oh my
god that's why I felt the need to wear
these buns that's why yeah baby yeah a
lot of people are mentioning James Bond
I have only seen one James Bond film and
it was the first one that Daniel Craig
was fitted so let me know if you'd like
to see any James Bond films I have a
couple really fun ones planned for the
next few weeks so check them out that
sounded like just for the next few weeks
they'll be fun and then after that
they're gonna be garbage just total crap
thank you for watching they're all gonna
be fine and none of them are gonna be
garbage I'll see you next week and
remember I also like to live dangerous
[Music]
[Applause]
you